she would hit me up on Instagram to come
out after the show she was with five
girlfriends so I just show up and they
all have tattoos and they're talking
about the bartender's micropenis and I
was like yeah that sucks for him insult
a guy with a small dick in front of him
and see how angry he China's when I
dated a guy who referred to a girl he
dated as having one of her labias were
longer than the other so he called her
stroke that worse and I get to be
like kind of joking angry
oh well not at him I was just like haha
I'm never showing you mine which I
eventually definitely did she taught him
at least mine has a stroke on both sides
[Music]
so yeah you got mad cuz they were making
fun of your penis like how dare you say
that about us we're good people we're
good people will go down on you we'll
finger you will love you cuz that's all
of Portland that is olive oil and I
never went to no I didn't go to one but
no they ended up going into a photo
booth and taking pictures of their own
tits and giving it to me as like as an
appreciation and I think I probably
could have that's like the when in
Hawaii when you get a little-a yeah
tattooed tits
everyone has tattoos there it's very
earth I I like it I don't know sometimes
at least I used to look at like when
someone would have a ton of tattoos as
dirty and I'd be like oh they probably
have all the STDs like that would go
through my head but now since I have
them oh I'm like yeah it's pretty cool
it's wrinkled maybe I'll get a tattoo
yeah that's that's cuz their mom my mom
has COPD emphysema and then you're like
you want to date someone like your mom
like and yeah your mom is a tank people
don't know that people with emphysema
have tanks oh really yeah you have to
like bridge okay my mom has really bad
emphasis your joke I'm helping him write
a joke cuz he I was like everyone dates
men always go after their moms and so
his mom has emphysema so he should say
that so mom has an accident you have to
say she has an oxygen she's always on
oxygen she has a tank with a tube so
I've been dating a lot of scuba divers
I'm like can you wear it to dinner yeah
the problem is they're never on land
come on you got a look at another
reef really yeah all of the
states have to happen in the ocean just
so these women can remind me I like
tattoos on guys when they're they don't
win their mistakes when they're like I
got this when I was 18 it means nothing
and literally means nothing I don't know
why I got at my buddy
like I like bad stories with tattoos not
intentionally bad where they're like
it's a joke weak
like truly meant something to them at
one time and now it's so humiliating
it's like wearing a TBT on you
constantly a reminder of when you were
lame and you like weren't cool you know
what I mean
yeah I like that but I don't like fresh
tattoos with like its new meaning or if
somebody yeah I told you about the guy I
went out with that had the broccoli
tattoo
yeah that's pretty gross actually take
that back Adam Levine last night at the
Super Bowl
everything I know everyone was so not
into that but I'd only be nice so what
about like if you have sleeves and stuff
and then you're like an accountant like
I feel like there's like a lot of like
people in Brooklyn are like I'm like
California across the stomach this guy
didn't like him or something like fat
guy in the Midwest just did one and
wrote Illinois across it about Bieber
Bieber is covered right now to me it
just says that you are you probably
would have cut in another world like
it's a form of cutting I know that a lot
of people get tattoos for the pain of it
and that's why I'd be appealing to me I
think I would like the pain of it and
some people like get off on that and I
think that's why a lot of people can't
stop getting them but also it's it
there's got a piece case studies about
people that get tattoos and mentally
what they how different they are the
people who choose not to I don't know I
got my what's the closest to a tattoo
thing you've done you do do something
rebellious
I used to pick really a lot of certain
parts of my skin or pull hair out like
an OCD pain thing okay you had
trichotillomania a tiny bit yeah periods
of time when I was a kid a lot of people
do not trigger Atilla mania so much is
like pressing pressure points and
hurting my skin like it had to be I've
never talked about this here here until
it would like almost bleed yeah or
chewing parts of my mouth and then I'd
stop it yeah is yeah sometime you'll get
into that again so many people do that I
mean the more that I have female
friendships and and in a adult life and
we're getting further away from the
stuff we did as teens like more of it's
coming out women are becoming more
comfortable talking about like yeah I
picked out all my hair
when I was 17 or they're currently doing
it like a lot of people have these
things I don't think the picking out
your hair is as like people can be more
open about eating disorders than that at
this point like I've but I I hear you I
know a lot of you are out there it's
never been my thing but it could have
been my thing hmm
I don't judge that at all but it is that
is a thing that girls do a lot and I
only cut once after I got caught
shoplifting I was just like so mad at
myself and I wanted to like punish
myself so I understood cutting in that
moment yeah so that to me I get it
but tattoos yeah I've just never had
anything that I just care enough about
yeah I think that's the classic Figment
reason that people give that they don't
get tattoos but I got my nose pierced I
was 18 oh really
yeah septum no side side because I knew
I researched it and I knew that like I
have enough acne scars there that it
would just the worst it would look like
a net it would blend in so who cares
it's not gonna be a I knew that there
was an out I really liked the ankh
symbol the Egyptian ankh symbol which
kind of looks like a female symbol when
I was like 14 through 18 thank God I
didn't get it tattooed because I wanted
like a big one on my ankle but I always
sort of thought I was judgmental about
tattoos so I never did it yeah I think I
got this like the top of my ear I
thought that was pretty rebellious does
that hurt and then it got like infected
and then like I thought like how I felt
horribly dead it was connected to my ear
and then my dad was like yeah you're
right and I think he was just saying
that because like so he got like a
little infected and then I like didn't
feel healthy and so then I can he's gone
there but you he doesn't walk you to the
where he's good you mean that you got
the flu or something or an ear infection
yeah I just was feeling off oh like your
canal infection I don't know it was
infected on the top of my ear and then I
started to feel sick but then I
connected it to the ear but it's
probably just I had the sniffles you
know what I mean so right but then when
I told my dad who's a doctor he was like
yeah you're probably right but I just
thinking and why he didn't want the
freaking earring he didn't want his son
to have an earring yeah
there's a joke there too somewhere what
I can help you develop it no no I think
he's got it
I think I'm here
[Music]
you